ahora vamos a hablar de la respuesta
natural de un circuito lc un circuito
inductor capacitor y este es un circuito
bastante interesante ya que tiene dos
elementos que almacenan energía en los
vídeos anteriores hemos visto circuitos
con solo un elemento que almacena
energía ya sea una c o una l pero en
esta ocasión los vamos a tener juntos
para ver cómo funcionan en pareja y en
este circuito no hay resistencia así que
es interesante porque tenemos dos
elementos que almacenan energía esto qué
significa significa que para un
capacitor hay cierta carga almacenada en
el capacitor y esto típicamente
significa que tenemos un exceso de carga
en uno de los lados o placas en este
caso tenemos un exceso de carga positiva
en la placa superior o también podríamos
decir que hay una ausencia de carga
negativa en la placa superior y al mismo
tiempo tenemos un exceso de carga
negativa en la placa de abajo y es a
esto a lo que nos referimos cuando
decimos que el capacitor está
almacenando carga ahora cómo es que un
inductor almacena energía el inductor
almacena energía en un campo magnético
se encuentra en el espacio alrededor de
el inductor así que cuando tenemos
corriente que pasa a través de un
inductor su energía se va a almacenar en
un campo magnético así y estos son
nuestros dos elementos que almacenan
energía algo que sabemos de cv en el
capacitor es que q es igual hace por ver
así que sí aquí tenemos una q significa
que también tendremos un voltaje aquí y
ese es el voltaje que vamos a rastrear
en este circuito que es el voltaje entre
estos dos nodos de aquí y debido a que
tenemos un inductor algo interesante es
la dirección de la corriente en el
inductor la dirección de nuestra
corriente tiene este sentido y algo que
quiero hacer notar es que si defino que
la corriente del inductor va hacia abajo
esa misma corriente irá hacia arriba por
el capacitor
así que el reto es conocer cuál es la
respuesta natural de este circuito es
decir vamos a poner cierta energía en él
en este caso pondremos cierta q en el
capacitor y dejaremos que comience en
cero y después dejaremos solo al
circuito para ver cómo se comporta y eso
significa encontrar cuál es el voltaje
como función del tiempo y la corriente
como función del tiempo y ambas cosas
representan la respuesta natural de un
circuito ls lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es predecir las formas de ve
y ahorita vamos a hacer esto
intuitivamente y en los siguientes
vídeos haremos esto con precisión
matemática y al final veremos si el
resultado matemático coincide con
nuestra intuición
así que aquí vamos a rastrear qué le
sucede a la carga conforme este circuito
sigue su respuesta natural así que
primero vamos a escribir las ecuaciones
de cada uno de los elementos de este
circuito y para el inductor sabemos qué
b es igual a l por ley de t el voltaje
es proporcional al valor de la
inductancia multiplicada por la
pendiente de la corriente o la tasa de
cambio de la corriente y para un
capacitor sabemos que es igual a c que
multiplica a la pendiente del voltaje
que es de b dt y algo que sabemos es que
ambas ecuaciones son verdaderas sin
importar el tiempo lo cual nos va a
ayudar mucho y la forma en que vamos a
resolver esto intuitivamente es rastrear
a la carga y ver qué es lo que sucede
con la corriente y ver qué ocurre
momento a momento en el circuito
conforme esta carga se mueve lo que voy
a hacer para tener cierta configuración
voy a quitar una parte del circuito y en
su lugar voy a poner un interruptor y
este interruptor se va a cerrar cuando
el tiempo sea igual a 0 así que antes de
que se cierre el circuito vamos a
guardar cierta carga en el capacitor por
lo que habrá un voltaje en el capacitor
y este voltaje será de 0 por lo que el
voltaje cuando t es menor que cero es
igual a b 0 que más sabemos pues cuando
el interruptor está abierto quiere decir
que la corriente en este circuito va a
ser igual a 0 así que ponemos que y
cuando t es menor que cero va a ser
igual a cero así que hay dos cosas que
conocemos de este circuito y ya estamos
listos para cerrar el interruptor vamos
a detenernos en este momento y
continuaremos en el siguiente vídeo